Just follow every move
Touch me
Let me know you wanted to
We don't have to leave
We need
It's a moment that I've been waiting for this is the original first generation iPhone. This is the 8 gigabyte model?
I got it on eBay, and I don't even know if it's legit
But I'm pretty sure it is
I searched the serial number the IMEI number and everything
Seems to have checked out it hasn't been activated the serial number has never been registered with Apple fingers crossed because I am doing today
an unboxing of
the first generation iPhone and it's crazy because I never
Did do an unboxing over the first gen iPhone the only unboxing that I did do of the original iPhone?
Was a phone bill you guys have never seen this. This is back in the day when I'd first got my phone
It was a 300-page iPhone bill, so essentially in some sort of weird roundabout way. I did unbox this phone
Just phone bill have an idea and I had to switch to AT&T okay. That's wonderful while I got my first 18d built
In a box
This phone means so much to me
And there's a lot of sentimental value
And the fact that I never really got a chance to unbox the original one may have been scouring
eBay for the past couple of years trying to find one that was legit within minutes
We will know I feel like this is such a big moment
I don't even know what to do like I should I I don't know should I put on a party dress or something?
I'm not I don't know
I maybe I just open it hope for the best what knife would I have used in 2007?
I don't even know some of the concerns that I have on this box that may potentially
Lead me to believe that it's not real is this little packaging line right here
There's a few tears of greater this has been around for 11 years, so it's trying to find some original unboxings
and I saw some original photos and in those original photos of the original iPhone it looked like they used to have this type of
Line in packaging, so I thought it's gotta be real. I think I'm putting too much. Hope and effort into boxing this one
I just could open it and find out here. We go. We're gonna use this one. Wow. This is a lot of pressure. Oh
Gosh I'm so signed so I might cry this is so stupid. Don't cry just seemed. Oh cried. Don't be a baby oh
My gosh this is happening it's happening. It's happening. Oh wow
Here it is
What's my heart rate
I caught my heart rate is that it's actually 92 right now
Which is kind of crazy because that's not what my resting heart rate. Usually is. It's averaging of like oh my god
It's 111 right now. My heart rate is 111
112 I'm getting so worked up. Please don't cry
Like I'm actually getting a really teary-eyed right now and like whether this is real or whether it's not the fact that I'm here
Unboxing this 11 years later, and I'm still doing something that I absolutely love to do is so incredible
I'm so emotional right now. This is actually crazy, I oh
So far this looks pretty legit
There's like a little dad here. Oh gosh. No my baby my baby
So far everything looks pretty good
Before we get into the phone, let's see what else is in the box so has this clear little front
I don't even remember doing this unboxing originally here
it is everything is very snugly fit in here, which makes me believe this has never been opened before a
Charging brick a
Dock, I do not even remember this coming with a dog. That's crazy
Here's our charging cable. Oh my gosh
You are such a sweet, so it's all. I have not seen you in so long
And last but not least
Earpods
Definitely having some flashbacks to this 30 pin connector. I mean I haven't seen one of these in such a long time
I guess I saw on the 3GS, but still I honestly forgot that they even had this
Now let's see what came inside of these directions you don't want to rip it. This is this is my baby?
Fingertips, oh hello
Came with a nice cleaning cloth
Lay you down very very gently. That's what we're gonna put you here's our directions. I mean there's
There's a lot
We've also got the original white stickers
I am putting this all back right where I got it from important product information
This just looks like some safety things I think contain sensitive components do not bend drop a crush
I felt your concern about scratching iPhone you can buy one of the many cases sold separately
I should do a dramatic reading of this for a YouTube video. I might as well
I'm gonna be milking these iPhone original views for a very long time
Enjoy an unboxing and also re boxing because I don't want any of my things to get damaged so I guess this only leaves us
With one more thing to do unwrap the phone and turn it on let's get our charging brick ready
That is that is really on there
You like it's gonna
Rip this whole screen off. I guess this has been on there for
Doesn't have a smell for like a what 11 years
Do you guys think this will actually turn on do you think this will even work at all?
It's charging it's charging. There's a charging if there's there's a charge look look look. It's charging. I am so excited
I'm gonna let this charge for a little bit, and then I'm gonna come back
And we will just do some investigating just see what we can do with this thing just been walking around the house
patiently waiting for this moment let's see if it'll turn on Oh
What you may have connected to iTunes
That's a problem oh no I can't do that this version of iTunes has not been out for 11 years
Okay, well if it wants me to connect it iTunes, then that's what I'm gonna do
Know I know you know I know I'm Shh. Calm yourself opening up iTunes
Itunes cannot connect to the iPhone because an invalid response is received from the device. It's valid
Let me let show me. Oh god. How am I gonna even get this thing to work?
oh
Boy okay download full version of iTunes I can't use this
Okay, so I'm good to go getting it a PC this is gonna work. I promise actually. I don't promise
Supported systems Windows XP well on my own. This is not gonna work. Oh
Gosh the real bottom line is the phone is legit. It looks brand-new. It's never been activated before
I don't have to jailbreak it. Oh will I have to jailbreak it? I'm not sure this is gonna
Take a lot more time than I have currently right now to dedicate to this but stay tuned because I will
Get this phone to work. No matter what I have to do well guys. Thank you so much for watching
I look forward to doing a little bit more of investigating with this phone. I'll see you guys in the next video
I'm gonna get back to
Working if you guys have any suggestions for me leave those in the comments below as of this point
I have done
Absolutely zero research on how to get this to work, so I have a feeling that between your comments
My google searches and a little bit more investigation
We will be able to get this thing up and running in no time. This is no that's not what I wanted to do
Yeah, do whatever you want